it's good now you're good
hold up
testing one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
seven eight nine that's all
I'm just gonna testing right now it says
chain cable you guys hear anything
anything at all testing one two three
four okay
no I'm whispering so we don't do it he's
he's on his way back up so it's actually
gonna go up
all right all right
you're doing the heavy lifting a quick
intro all right
well let me
thank everybody for the opportunity and
privilege of your time and I want to
welcome the president back uh to the Bay
Area it's nice as I told the president
to be back here uh without the backdrop
of a disaster but we are here mindful uh
of this slow-moving disaster which has
presented itself Anew particularly here
in the state of California uh through
extremes extreme heat extreme drought
extreme weather and we're here mindful
of our role and responsibility to do
more and do better but I also am mindful
that we're here in California and I want
to just take the opportunity to brag a
little bit a state of dreamers of doers
of innovators a state that long has
prided itself on being on the leading
and cutting edge of new ideas here we
are in the Bay Area the source of so
much energy and Innovation literally and
figuratively a stone's throw away from
Palo Alto we love to say about this
region the future happens here first and
as it relates to the issue of climate
change we are also mindful of our role
and responsibility to address it and so
much of I think what makes California
unique and special is demotionally
exampled in the work we have done to
tackle head-on the issue of climate
change and that goes back decades in
fact year of my birth 1967 the
California resources board was conceived
by a republican Governor at the time
Clean Air Act just three years later
codifying California's leadership
with the work that President Nixon
advanced again
Republicans not just Democrats were
leading the way in terms of addressing
our efforts to mitigate the most acute
impacts of climate change that has
significantly changed over the course of
the last half century and we're here
mindful of that as a backdrop but also
mindful of the extraordinary progress
that President Biden has made over the
course of the last number of years
there's simply no president in modern
American history it's done more to
deliver
on the promise of addressing head-on the
issue of climate change than President
Joe Biden I cannot be more privileged
and pleased not only to assert that but
to lay claim that with the IRA and
congresswoman's extraordinary work that
we're already seeing unprecedented
Investments all across the United States
of America to advance the call that was
made in August of last year and
California of course is one of many
states that's a beneficiary of those
Investments we have in California in
closing six times more clean energy jobs
than we do fossil fuel jobs California
is produced roughly one out of every
four clean energy jobs in America 27
percent this state Prides itself again
on being on the leading and cutting edge
of this transition and we're proving we
can do it and grow our economy but we
need to do it with remarkably talented
people and we need to create an energy
and a framework to create a generation
of doers not just dreamers and that's
why it's my honor to introduce one of
those doers who's part of this
remarkable program that we established a
few years ago called the California
climate Corps in the spirit Mr President
of Sarge Shriver and the spirit of our
time we say it often the happiest people
in the world are those that volunteer
the tallest people all those have been
down on one knee to help lift other
people up and to see the energy the
passion and action of these young people
displayed all across the state of
California that just haven't gotten the
memo they don't buy into the cynicism
the negativity and the fear and the
division
in so many ways they're the antidote to
all of that
and China is one of those remarkable
young leaders that's taking her action
and passion locally and is driving
change and inspiring others throughout
the state of California and so I
couldn't be more honored to have the
privilege of introducing China who will
be introducing you appropriately Mr
President welcome back to the great
state of California and it's my honor to
introduce China Thai
[Applause]
good afternoon it's an honor to be here
my name is China Thai I'm a 2019 UC
Riverside graduate I majored in
sustainability studies and grew
interested in community-led climate
advocacy
I currently serve as an Americorps
member and a California climate action
Corps fellow at White Pony Express an
organization that is committed to aiding
those in need
we help combat climate change and fight
food insecurity by
diverting fresh healthy foods from
landfills and redistributing it to
underserved communities
in other words we're
rescuing surplus food and giving it to
the people most in need
our work
also has another important benefit
when we reduce the edible surplus food
from ending up in landfills we're also
reducing methane a harmful pollutant
that is a major driver in the climate
crisis
our work took on a new meaning during
the recent Spate of punishable storms in
Canada California
we when we helped
our when we helped the unhoused by
giving them tarps and other necessities
they
um
sorry
because of the recent storms they lost
everything they owned so when we helped
unhoused through the treacherous storms
that is a part of us taking action and
helping those in need
so you see Californians live in the
consequential
crisis of the climate
um climate change affects us all and it
disproportionately affects those that
are most vulnerable
for my generation this is the issue of
our time
so that's why I am so proud that we have
a commander-in-chief that is
believes this to his core
he understands that
um he has taken bold climate action
since day one
by securing the most consequential
climate legislation in history
he has been a powerful leader in the
fight against climate change and the
future Generations will be better for it
here in California and all across
America
it is my honor to introduce President
Joe Biden
[Applause]
well thank you China
that introduction
Governor Newsom
I tell you what
it's nice to be here as you said working
on something that's
positive thing going forward and not
fixing something to happen very well
very badly
we spent a lot of time in helicopters
flying over areas that needed help folks
uh I want to thank
Anna thank you kid you've been
incredible you've been a friend for a
long long time in the Congress when I
was in the Senate and you've done
remarkable work
parted everything from protecting the
environment to providing improving the
lives of the people in this district and
thanks to all the climate leaders that
are here today
you know we just visited the salt marsh
as you saw we walked down to the end of
the safety Bay project safer Bay project
and a public-private partnership that's
harnessing the nature of our ability to
do with this young woman in China did
you know one of the I always say I've
never and I mean it sincerely I've been
around a long time in public life I got
elected when I was about your age when I
was 28 years old
and you know what I've never been more
optimistic you and I were talking about
that privately I swear to God I've never
been more optimistic in my life and the
reason I'm optimistic is because of this
generation
it's the best educated the most engaged
the most involved and the most
consequential they're in they're in
governor was telling me about when they
announced the program there's 3 000
slots and about 10 000 people
immediately signed on try to sign on
well look these Wetlands act as a
critical buffer between the rising ties
and the communities at risk
protecting homes property and
infrastructure against flooding they
also absorb carbon dioxide from the air
and we're right next to Route 101 and
where cars and trucks emit a lot of
carbon pollution
what we're seeing here is an amazing
success story of how you can work
together to make our communities more
climate resilient
it matters it matters resiliency matters
you know I've toured many sites across
the country that clearly show climate
change is a genuine exit is the
existential threat to you
the existential threat to humanity here
in California the governor you you and I
stood together with First Responders
near Monterey Bay after touring the
damage that was done the devastating
storms caused historic flooding that
killed 21 people
that comes on the heels of the worst
droughts in California and more than a
millennia and the highest sea level rise
in more than a century
I've seen Wildfire Devastation across
the West Burning more acres to the
ground than slower square miles in the
state of Maryland that's how much got
burned in the ground and all the
just flying over is devastating
there's been historic tornadoes and
flooding in the Midwest and the
southeast
and just last week across the east coast
and Midwest we saw what you've already
seen here in California millions of
Americans sheltered indoors the air not
safe to breathe orange Haze covering the
sky
it's incredible
by the way to address those Wildfire
smoke that's coming from Canada we're
sharing Cutting Edge technology that's
already used here in California to help
detect early fires and help them and
send in addition to that firefighters
and and tankers as well folks the
impacts we're seeing in climate change
are only going to get more frequent and
more ferocious and more costly last year
alone last year alone natural disasters
in America caused
165 billion dollars in damage just last
year alone 165 billion dollars in damage
but the worsening impacts are not
inevitable building on our incredible
effort locally my Administration is
doing all we can to help recover and
build so we can be prepared to and adapt
you know it's all part of my invest in
America agenda the governor was
referencing it starts with the most
significant climate investment law ever
anywhere in the history of the world
over billions and billions 368 billion
dollars 369 to be precise in clean
energy development environmental justice
conservation is so much more
we will cut one billion tons of carbon
emission a year create millions of good
paying jobs it's already attracting
billions of dollars in the private
sector because business is realizing
it's overwhelming in their interest as a
matter of fact a couple businesses are
suing Banks because they want to
consider whether or not they're
environmentally anyway I won't get into
all that I'll get
but I want to emphasize again we're
taking the most aggressive climate
action ever it's focused on mitigation
which means historic investments in
developing clean energy by reducing
dependence on fossil fuel and resilience
which means communities communities can
better withstand the impacts of climate
change and extreme weather with the
combination of bipartisan infrastructure
law and the inflation reduction act in
the chips and science act we've invested
more than 50 billion dollars so far in
climate resilience nearly 9 billion to
make Transportation infrastructure more
resilient by elevating roads and bridges
above projected flood zones 13 billion
to decrease the wild fire risk and
improve Forest Health and Pain for
firefighters who risk their lives every
day
drought mitigation 15.4 billion dollars
to bolster the West resilience to
drought these Investments are being made
in the context of a mega drought
affecting the Colorado River basin 40
million 40 million Americans already
drinking water thousands of farmers
relying for integration and 40 million
count on that River and so do the
farmers
6.6 billion dollars in coastal
resilience restoration of reefs and
construction of other infrastructure to
mitigate storm damage plus more than 17
billion dollars in the bipartis
infrastructure law to bolster resilience
for Coastal water and waterways
infrastructure including funding to
address food floods storms and hurricane
risks and restore Coastal ecosystems
climate smart agriculture nearly 20
billion dollars in funding for precision
aggregate irrigation and planting cover
crops plus a one billion dollar America
the Beautiful challenge to accelerate
locally LED conservation efforts folks
flood mitigation 3.5 million dollars
reduced and eliminate the risk of
repetitive flood damage to buildings
plus one billion dollars in funding
mitigation measures to increase
Community resilience like supporting
adaptations of Hazard resistant building
codes and maybe most important I've
committed that by 2020 we will have
conserved 30 percent of all the lands
and Waters the United States as
jurisdiction over and simultaneously
reduce emissions to blunt climate impact
we're on our way
conservation land and water we put war
in conservation and land and water than
any president in the history of the
United States since but John Kennedy
we're leading the way to in Palo Alto in
East Palo Alto and to Belhaven for
instance the local non-profit called
climate resilient communities gives
Community thank you are you all part of
that thank you gives members a voice and
plan an adaptation I'm here today to
announce that we're putting our critical
climate investment to work folks first
starting tomorrow the department of
Congress Commerce will launch the first
and largest competitive climate
resilience Regional challenge to provide
600 million dollars to Coastal and great
lake communities that are building
projects to protect against impacts of
climate change from sea level rise
flooding and storm surge we're investing
in the people in places that haven't
been hit the hardest but who are also on
the front lines of leading us forward
folks second thing we're doing the
department of energy is going to
announce that it's investing more than
two billion dollars to modernize our
electric grid to be more climate
resilient including more than 67 million
dollars starting off in California that
funding can help ensure our electric
crit is stronger that the lights and air
conditioning and internet stay on during
heat waves and storms and other climate
events so the lights can stand on
hostile operating rooms nursing home and
so many other critical care facilities
and third later this year we're hosting
the first ever White House Summit that
convenes local state travel and
territorial leaders focused on climate
resilience it's going to include a road
map for how these historic climate
actions are going to build more climate
resilient communities all across America
saving lives and homes providing peace
of mind
this is how we're going to meet the
moment this is how we're going to
unfortunately some of our migrant
Republican friends in Congress are
continuing to try to undo all the
progress we've already made in the first
two and a half years
they were holding the country hostage
over the debt limit unless I would gut
the climate provisions of the inflation
reduction Act
I was determined not to let that happen
with your significant help and I mean
that sincerely all of you here
particularly Anna in the house and the
Congress we didn't let that happen and
in the end we didn't just protect some
of the climate money and clean energy
provision we protected every single
solitary one
[Applause]
if this ain't your father's Republican
Party
they're back at it again with another
bill to repeal the same Provisions but
with your help we're going to stop them
again
let me close to this throughout our
history we're the only nation in the
world that has come out of every crisis
we've entered stronger than we went into
it we're doing it again here in the
climate crisis when I think of climate I
think of jobs when I think of climate I
think of innovation when I look at John
a climate I think attorney parallel into
progress that's why I'm so optimistic
about the future I really am
I just have to remember who the hell we
are we're the United States of America
for God's sake there's nothing nothing
beyond our capacity if we work together
and that's what all of you are doing
here have been doing we're going to
continue to do and God bless you all to
may God protect our church let's go get
them let's get this done
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you